mit dem film bereitet betroffenen über
sexuelle übergriffe sei wahrscheinlich
sagte salesch den look
tochterfirma gewusst was mir passiert
ich habe andere thema
karstadt tätig sind und ausgeführt oder
stirb in der moment
sexualisierte übergriffe sind die unsere
gesellschaft immer noch tabu thema
umso mehr wenn es opfer in marsch das
geht doch nicht geil ist das denn so ein
bomber text vor als wenn du wird von
einer frau gemacht werden
wie wenn das so war das immer lustig
es geht um anzeige und es konzerte zu
verteidigen nur wenige mandl brachte es
schläge
nachdem dann das sächsische nachdem
medien kommen bin ja nicht
wieder gefüllt aber irgendwann auch die
gesamt was du nach schmitten
so sorgen die autos von dem fehler
betroffen zwei trawler und verstorben so
das thema ist tabu
[Musik]
um mit meiner können jetzt hätte wo
sexuelle übergriffe fahrer haben einen
aufruf gestartet und eine wo sich auf
der aufruf gemeldet hat ist der look
back at 24 und ist mit 18 von einem
anderen mann sexuell genötigt wurde ich
drifte luca im fitness zum ihn abholen
sport ist ein ausgleich zum
arbeitsalltag
übrigens als nötigung gilt wenn eine
person zu dick von rabbi schlaf ähnliche
oder der sexuelle handlung nötig wird um
ungestört über die taz heute können wir
zweimal zum lockerheit
im vorsprung hat mit lukas zelt das sie
mit 18 von dem kollegen modelagentur in
hollywood ist das modell versuche und
ich zum casting
maximal erzähle was da passiert ist
bis ich töte bis sie nicht mehr
eigentlich nicht größer bis dahin ja im
moment ist der kollege hat mit der
agentur ja irgendwie einen
professionellen eindruck gemacht dass
die agentur jetzt geht alles die person
und kostet
weniger emotionen nicht mehr so wie du
bist die ganze situation können wir
viele emotionen zeigen und
finde mich gestanden und hat mir den
verhinderten
auf eine lange und
tolle quasi und der name war etwas das
ich
halte die personen
die wenig gewusst was mir passiert ist
das ganze session nachdem ideen gegangen
bin jahren nicht mehr
eigentlich auch gewitter durchgeführt
aber auch für die gesamt
würde ich mein ich danke
das war bis jetzt noch nicht passieren
oder das passiert einmal durch
den tanks michigans arbeitet und schaum
ist
15 jahre lang hätte luca nehmen vor dem
vorfall erzählt anni ziehen ihre
damalige freundin bisher erfahren hat
dass es von gleicher modelagentur vitry
opfer geht durch sich mit infos und
entscheidet sich zur opferhilfe die
vermieter themen arbeit und erstellt
oder 16mal der familie der zelle im
hotel überwindet braucht
der stücke da will muss so langsam
verdrängt hat
das habe ich dafür dass ich wieder
sauber dem entsetzen also ich hab im
nachhinein betrachtet wichtig sie nun
sagen doch irgendwo sachlich haben laut
beck nun hat und einmal
befriedet quasi
amerika irgendwo ja diesmal unter dem
ich darüber
umso mehr ist eben einfach arbeiten so
besser gehabt also umso besser kann man
damit um gar nichts gefühlt ich treffe
mich mit dem martin bachmann er durch
sexy look und über 20 jahre lang in
meiner prioritäten klar es erfordert
bedeutend mehr frauen sexualisierte
übergriffe auseinander und trotzdem ist
es für die jemand was betrifft sehr
schwierig und zwar mit november passiert
ist tabu ist grundsätzlich nicht gott
und der zusage jolie der charakter hätte
dass wir aber ob sie
ähnlich wie nie zuvor kommt sich nichts
könne wenig und linie zuvor und wenn es
denn aber ist sind ja alle unsicher also
die betroffenen selber das umfeld
behörden wenn man würde den euro immer
wieder in frage berichtet wollen wir
ihnen nicht einfach so glaubt sondern es
kommt doch nicht so schlimm geht das
anders gemeint ist doch cool schönpass
ideen daraus dass man noch wohl fühlen
ich darf das problem haus sondern
sind immer oft es geht doch nicht geil
sondern so ein dominanter text vor als
wenn du wird von einer frau gemacht
werden
wie wenn du so weit dass es immer lustig
nein natürlich nicht
sondern man ist eigentlich los sturm
eigentlich nicht aber so die erwartet
dass wir immer offen wenn sie zum thema
sexualität ist kompletter blödsinn aber
erhöht den druck dass wenn
zuverlässig ist vielmehr dass sie geht
aber ja nomine hemd über das spricht
politiker manuele ab zu nennen sind mit
ihm gemacht dass er anonym blieb er ist
mit die 20 und hedge um minderjährige
opfer sexuellen übergriff erlebt
ich habe mit dem manual vorher schon mal
telefoniert er hat mir erzählt dass er
schon als kind schwierige
familienverhältnisse
mit 15 hätte reinschnuppern wie meine
bekannte von der familie nach vorne der
260 lehrmeister mit mlb die vaterrolle
übernommen und ist eine wichtige
bezugsperson wurde für ihn
was ihm genau passiert ist hat er
aufgeschrieben und heizöfen tablette
bieten
ich habe jetzt bloß wo wir dazu erklärt
wird anerkannt
meine person wird auch noch so wenig b
und dann ist da erst die
tatsächliche übergriff stattgefunden
nachdem er das alte logo komplett
gundheim ins andere lager gebracht hat
dann hätte musik spielt und sie muss so
verpackt dass sie nie kommt um mich
klagt ich habe mich sehr wohl gefühlt
ich danke
akzeptiert mit so wenig wie und ich
werde also quasi für mich lohnt in rom
archiv partizipieren
und es schon mal mit so einer
freundschaftlichen umarmung
und eltern in der abwehr und glied
gelangt und ra und ich
zog zuckt der schweiz komplett schwieger
ich komm nicht schwer trauriger will es
sich wir so eine
verzerrte moment verzerrt die realität
will aus wie mit können und
gleichzeitig die villa wieder mit mit
angeordnet haben trotz dem übergriff ist
emanuel immer mehr in eine psychische
abhängigkeit zum lehrmeister gerutscht
und gleichzeitig hätte sich für sie in
der familie abkapselt ist für die haikus
zucker also obwohl es zu einem übergriff
erträumt
hätten angefangen wenn sie halt nicht
das gemacht habe aus ich halte was
angefangen mich eher niedrige für
anderen arbeitskollegen als wir die
ganze zuneigung und wertschätzung dieses
spiel noch eine
stufe über
monate weg ist es immer schlimmer wurde
all die körperliche übergriffe da hat
mir
rosen aberzogen
und missbraucht
und ausgebeutet stirb in dem moment
bewusstlos
ich habe eine starke buch rca
nämlich selber und hier schreien aus der
situation bis nach
hätte haye
kann niemals kochen
und dann ist halt nur zwei jahre hinweg
meistens friedlich und
sonstigen
die woche
und da hätten vettel gemacht
hat mich zu oralverkehr zu machen das
ist heute immer die gleiche spieler
alexej gemacht hättest die backup
jährige gab an die mitgemacht jetzt denn
wir die emotionale zuneigung noch zwei
jahre was ihm immer schlechter gegangen
ist erhält sogar suizidgedanken
yahoo selbst gemerkt dass er bis nicht
stimmt der manuell hemers erster alles
für sie missbrauch verzählt und sind
lehrmeister wegen sexueller nötigung
sexueller handlungen mit abhängigen und
war kinderpornografische fotos ab zeigt
und was ist der umschlag gaben die punkt
sehe dass du das mal machen
das ist wichtig wenn es trocken ist den
ich aber im fokus und es ist um mich
gang und für mich ist um kräftig
gegangen um sage hey was du gemacht hast
mitten im leben zu sorgen wie auch das
ist falsch frz mitarbeiters tag lang auf
sexuelle handlung mit abhängigen
natürlich wird bereits verjährt im
damaligen 8 ist verjährungsfrist kürzung
nach
752 oder die sexuelle nötigung ist
natürlich der staatsanwaltschaft klare
beweis für die nötigung verhalten
[Musik]
wegen mir gerade sprachlos
also es hat mich mekka berührt es ist
unglaublich was ihnen passiert ist und
was ich nur unglaubliche finde ich dass
das im rechtliche jetzt einfach für
jetzt ist
und da ein quasi fast ohne blüte vor und
raus gefühlt dass ich im manuel gar
nicht mal so wichtig ist jetzt wichtig
sie das auch aber das hätte dass er das
eher können wir anderem loswerden aber
ich bin trotzdem als zeichen und genau
dafür dass das tabu gelöst wird ist so
wichtig das urteil gefällt wartet und
dass man darf das duo das ist friert und
nur wichtige finde das ist einfach meine
meinung nach
gender neutral seit sie beinahe
vergewaltigt worden weil er es
vergewaltigt und
aktuell wird im schweizer sexueller
strafrechtlichen vergewaltigung so
definiert dass nur frauen vergewaltigt
werden es muss ein vaginale penetration
von meiner männlichen glieds
stattgefunden habe es schließt also
männer aus opel vergewaltigung muss für
den mangel ist es ein schock sie
erfahren dass es mal und gesetz nicht
vergewaltigt erwarten das hat er mir
erzählt
wenn also einmal ein sexueller
übergriffe fahrer hat zum beispiel
missbraucht wurde ist beginnt das vom
gesetz nicht aus vergewaltigung sondern
wird als sexuelle nötigung abdou
sexualstrafrecht das revidierte und da
wird gefordert dass die definition von
der vergewaltigung schlachten neutral
formuliert wird dort sind einmal darum
das strafmaß wird andere wenn amanda
können vergewaltigt werden sondern es
geht prinzipiell und gleichstellung
viele andere länder definiert übrigens
vergewaltigung viel breiter in
deutschland zum beispiel salat alle
sexuelle handlungen mit dem eindringen
körper verbunden sind als vergewaltigung
wie man an
mit dem markenrechtlich genau über die
ihr ungleichbehandlung im schweizer
gesetz
der mangel an der definition im recht
dass das achte album führt ich weiß
nicht ob es zum tabu führt ich glaube es
wird sicher helfen das esta buch und
abgebaut werden wenn im gesetz steht ja
wo alle menschen können vergewaltigt
werde und sich jedem fall strafbar und
kino nicht also botschaft lich sichere
gute wenn man soziale gesellschaftliche
diskussion das thematisiert und am
schluss einem gesetzt sofern abbilden wo
man sein 90
natürlich möglich dass man könnte opfer
von sexualisierter gewalt werde und dass
sie das recht auf unterstützung und
schutz und hilfe was wir als
gesellschaft vielleicht machen
betroffene einfacher gestalten ich
plädiere ich sehe das mit der
bildung investiert wo aber mehr als nur
gesundheitsvorsorge und biologie von 56
infos bekommen gott dass wenn ich
sexualität schön wie gott schöne sex wie
gut die beiden sie die gemeinde steinen
die sexuelle handlungen wie die machen
das flirt spiel wie wenn ich sechs an
honig und uns schön und akne haben was
man da eine größere sinn
auszusteigen
und für das buch zur zeit oft hilft
overesch wichtig allem luckey zirkus sie
zehn manager mit china zusammen
er hat es mir zerstampfen von der bezirk
noch nix aber
dann wo man glaubt welchem monat amick
sie sind oder so hat er sagt und öffnet
uns mit ca und als ich bin stolz auf sie
dass er mir gesagt keine zähler und auch
ein kaffeelöffel zähler also habe mich
sehr geehrt gefühlt aber natürlich hat
mich als [ __ ] schlacht das sind das
passiert
ist das ist auch ein hotel oder gar
durch reaktion haben wir das ich wusste
sich fragen wo man unterstützt
und ausgebaut und grafiktreiber jetzt
egal was passiert
schon bevor er seiner freundin der
vorfeld hätte luca alles in worte fassen
und sanitäter zeit und ein ist meine
prozesse und das gefühl
der gerichtsprozess hilft ihnen war
einst teil ich habe gerade wieder
linienbus und oder so einfach ihr schon
mal da und wird aber nichts gefühlt
ja auch dadurch dass man weiß okay sagt
es im ganzen
freistaat entstand durch flut erhalten
hilft ein ideal das verarbeiten
der modelagent ich wage sexueller
nötigung zu drei jahre freiheitsstrafe
wurde außerdem hat er luca 2000 franken
nur durch müsse zahlen
am anfang von dem film habe ich mich
gefragt wie es zu dem tabu der
gesellschaft grund und ich glaube das
liegt daran dass man sich ganz aufs amt
für das was ihnen passiert ist und ich
glaube aber ich freue mich das thema sie
scham behaftet obmann hannes oder das
ding dass sie noch das probieren nun mit
sich selber ausmachen und wenn darüber
reden und ich glaube dass rund genau wie
man ein bild wo man die gesellschaft
hält war einfach immer nur vermittelt
wird das thema mit schwächen aufzeigen
und so was passiert in einem monat und
was natürlich auch zu tag zum tabu führt
ist die gesetzliche grundlage wo einfach
nicht mehr auf manche betroffene gott
und wenn ich bis heute im film dann ist
es einfach das reden hilft rede ist so
wichtig und alwin i protagonisten und
alle mieter nicht weiter denn jetzt so
viel liter kurve wo sie mit der
krankheit kennt über das reine passiert
ist und jetzt seid ihr für euch wissen
was wir als gesellschaft machen zum das
tabu brach und dass es schlussendlich in
der betroffenen besser gott gibt mir
doch wie kommentare das ist jetzt ein
film über sexuelle übergriff erlebt in
dem film darauf zählen vier frauen für
ihre vergewaltigung
wenn du nicht mehr weiter vorweg dann
abonniert risiken